不是你唯一不会说谎的
就是价格本身
但要找到真正能让你赚钱的股票
并不是只看一个指标
也不是只听一句名言就能做到的事
许多人以为选股只要看财报
看技术指标
看新闻就好
但实际上市场里每一只涨跌
都牵涉到产业状况
筹码结构
技术格局
基金风向
国际情势
以及等体台股氛围
当你只抓到其中一个面向时
你永远猜不准市场
但当你能同时掌握全部面向
你会突然发现
市场的规律从来没有隐藏过
我是小王子
这是我在排股搭滚20年后
整理出的完整选股思维
今天的影片
我会把这些逻辑全部讲给你听
不长不审不简化
每个环节都讲到最细
而且你看到最后
我会公开一份
我自己每天都在使用的
中级选股步骤
你只要照着做
就能自行建立一套属于你的选股系统
我的身份不是分析师
而是每天真实在市场里面与主力
与行情对打的交易者
我的工作不是提供华丽的理论
而是提炼出最有效
最能提高胜率的逻辑
并把它组成能日复一日运作的系统
这支影片就是把这套架构完整交给你
真正的选股核心
不是找到会涨的股票
而是找到几率比别人高的位置
大多数散户选股的方式是看起来会涨就买
但真正的专业交易员
是透过严格的排除法
把不该碰的股票一个一个删掉
最后保留风险最低
胜率最高的那一些
股票市场不是考试
你不需要100分
你只需要站在机率比较高的位置
选股不是预设哪一帮会涨
而是降低你的错误率
提升你每一笔交易的期望值
这是你能在市场长期生存的唯一方式
在选股的第一个面下
也就是基本面之中
你需要先判断产业趋势
任何公司的股价走势
都会深受产业方向影响
一家公司就算经营的再好
如果它所处的产业正在萎缩
它的股价也未必能走强因此你要先理解这个产业未来三年是否有成长空间是否有全球趋势支撑是否存在被新科技淘汰的风险举例来说手机零组件产业近年竞争激烈
进入门槛被拉低
自然很难走长线
伺服器、AI、电动车等产业
则具备全球长线投入
具有更强的资金趋势
观光与餐饮属于景气循环体产
短线会很活跃
但不适合作为长线主题
如果没有先理解产业
你选股就像闭着眼睛射飞镖
接着你需要看财报与公司体制
其实你不需要读懂整份财报
只要抓住最重要的几个数字
例如营收的年增与月增是否呈现连续成长
毛利率是否维持在合理水准
营利率是否能有效反映公司真正的赚钱能力
费用率是否控制得以
以及EPS与股权收益率是否能持续创造股东价值
如果一间公司连三个月营收都没有成长
你就不该期待它股价一定会涨
不同類型的股票也必須對應不同的操作邏輯
長線股票的重點在產業趨勢與底製
法人會持續買進
中線波段股票則常見於營收成長或技術整理完畢
低財股的偏短線
通常會受到新聞預讀力影響較大
你不能用同利種眼光看所有股票
否則你會一直做錯方向
在第二個面向也就是技術面中
技術分析不是預測未來
而是用線圖讀懂市場參與者正在做什麼
你需要先看關鍵價位
也就是支撐壓力與趨勢線的位置
当支撑被守住就代表多方力量人带
压力无法突破就代表空方人站上风
而去实现代表市场的主要方向
比任何指标都更直觉
接着你要看量价关系
量是股票的灵魂
上涨必须有量
微档必须量缩
整理时量能要保持平稳
而真正的喷出之前
往往会出现奇怪的量能变化
我曾在券商VIP操盘室看到许多大户
他们都是先看量再看价
最后才决定部位
指标的部分你只需要均线
MACD與KD均線用來判斷趨勢方向MACD用來確認動能KD用來觀察短线转折然而指标不是用来预测而是用来辅助你如果想真正学懂技术分析
证据栏里有我最完整的技术分析实战课程
那是我20年的精华
我建议你一定要看
第三个面相是台股最重要的筹码面
筹码分为法人和主力
而你最应该学会的是观察投信
而券商主力
投信的买超讯号通常最干净
他们不会随便买
如果投信連續買超五天
你一定要去看那當國票背後的原因
券商主力的動作會比法輪更快
更敏感
他們會見倉、洗牌
適量、攻擊貨、出貨
而你要學會讀懂他們行為的節奏
第四個面向是新聞面
新聞包含真理多、假力多
以及過度解讀三種類型
當公司明明沒有什麼驚人的營收成長
新聞卻寫得像重大突破時
你要小心當法輪沒有動作
新聞卻天天寫力多時
你也要小心
新聞不是拿來決定買不買
而是判斷這個事件
是否會影響主要參與者的行為
第五个面向是大盘氛围
你必须观察大盘多空
OTC强弱法人资金
有向与国际行情
大环境不对
再好的股票也很难涨
大环境顺时
普通股票也能跑得飞快
当你完成五大面向之后
还不能急着买
选股只是一半
真正的关键在选后检查
你要先确认
现在是不是适合进场的行情
如果市场在空头阶段
即使你选到好股票
也容易被拖累
你还要判断这档股票
适合拨断还是短线
如果是短线题彩股
你不能抱太久
否则希望越大失望越大
你也要先设定停水与停力的位置
没有策略的进场
就是赌国
你还必须避免追高
你要买的是确认
不是激情
选股后的三天筹码非常重要
你要观察法联是否延续买超
大单方向是否改变
进场时
你不能一次买买
而要分批切入
最后你一定要问自己
你为什么买这档股票
如果你达不出来那你就不应该买所有选股方法最后都会回到同一件事那就是心態如果你的心态不对再好的选股逻辑也就不了你选股只是提高期望值而不是预测未来市场永远没有完美进场点
只有你能接受的风险
市场不是为你设计的
你不能把情绪投射进走势里
市场不会因为你委屈就补偿你
你也赚不到超出你认知的钱
因为超出你认知的获利
你只会吐回去
你要看居士
而不是一天的涨跌
你也不是要成为最强的人
而是要活得比别人久
风险不是你赔多少
而是你能不能承受
你最后需要的不是神奇公事
而是可以一直使用的选股逻辑
现在你已经学完全部内容
是时候公开我的终极选股步骤了
这是一套我真正每天都在使用的系统
每一档股票
我都会问五个问题
第一,基本面是否长期成长
营收是否持续改善
第二,技术面是否站在关键价位之上
第三,筹码面是否有主力或法人持续买进
第四,新闻是否为真实力多
而不是草题材
第五
大盘氛围是否适合进攻
如果当中有两项不合格
我就不碰
这套方法我用了十几年
它帮我避开无数的地雷
也让我能在多头与空头中为止稳定
如果你想把技术分析
与从马面学到真正能用的程度
我强内建议你去看资讯
哪里的课程
里面是我二十年来最完整的实战内容
而不是一般教科书式的理论
最后我把两份选顾清单给你
第一份是新手懒人版
也就是我认为最安全
最容易上手的版本
只要法人连续买超三天
营收三个月年增超过15%
股价站在月线之上
产业具有趋势
OTC 枪于大牌
就能纳入观察
第二分是高手版
如果主力五日连续买超
攻击量出现后回荡量
说不过关键价
大牌在多头或等你阶段
产业具长期成长性
技术面呈现多头排列
那就是我会动点追踪的标的
选股不是为了找下一只标股
而是让你站在更高的胜率
更低的风险之中
在市场里活得比别人久
我是小王子
我们下次见